des années des années à repenser à
ruminer mais impossible d'accepter que
cette aventure soit terminé lisa gacia
entremont et ce cri quoique jeunes masse
moi que je veuille je vais la retrouver
elle est celui qui m'a crevé l'oeil
alors oui je suis de retour et je viens
pour bouleverser l'histoire jeunes reste
le mât edimbourg me laisser croupir de
désespoir je ne peux plus me satisfaire
de la voir dans mes rêves je suis venu
pour la récupérer à son psy je n'essaye
pas j'en crève
je vais revoir aussi mon pire ennemi le
petit nabot ce livre de jack et en
m'approchant nuit j'ai tout de suite
créé entendu fameux deal tac je les
regardais de mont soleil que j'ai tout
de suite senti monter la pression
j'ai vu la haine dans les yeux de jack
il fallait qu'on ait une discussion
je lui ai expliqué que je n'étais plus
le même effet que le fait d'être borgne
avait changé moi aussi j'ai souffert des
différents que je ne suis pas venu là
pour me venger